This would be the numerator and this would be the denominator, fantastic algebra
skills if you figure those two out. Now, I know you might have never seen this
being distributed to a fraction. let's see how we can do that. We'll distribute
the 8x to each term in the numerator and to each term in the denominator. This
pare is the easiest of the multiplications we'll have 6 times 8x, which is 48x,
for the second one the x's will cancel. We will have an x in the numerator and
an x in the denominator. So we'll be left with 3 times 8 which equals 24. If
that seems a little off to you, think of 8x as 8x divided by 1. You know x
divided by x equals 1. So we're left with 3 times 8 which equals 24. For this
multiplication 8 divided by 4 equals 2. So we're left with x times 2 x, which
equals 2 x squared. And finally, for the last one, 1 8th of 8x would just be 1
x. 8 divided by 8 equals 1, so we're left with 1 x.